welcome back are you looking for a place
to ring in 2022 with some great food and
wine quasi beach house is here with more
on what they're offering welcome chef
josh hi how are you i'm good how's your
holiday it was great my daughter opened
a lot of presents so ate way too many
candy canes it was fun how was your
daughter three oh three so she can't
really
appreciate the smell of truffle just yet
right no no just smell the peanut butter
and jelly yes no truffles no exactly so
let's talk about what's on the menu for
new year's at cozy beach house so we
have a couple specials we're running uh
we have a variety of uh cocktails
focusing on lizzo cause she's gonna be
performing for us
this one is truth hertz
makes sense tequila hibiscus syrup a
little bit of lilith
lavender oh this is good
very refreshing yes but that's what i
love about kazi beach house it's kind of
a beach feel you feel like you're on an
island maybe if you want to pretend like
you're we even gotta you can't even see
for the holidays yes right
yeah you can see the pool from there
yeah see it's really a beach house okay
let's talk about the pizza so we have a
quattro famagio which is a four cheese
pizza
with three types of truffle in there so
we have the chopped truffle inside the
shaved truffle on top and then the
truffle oil oh that truffle oil you guys
this smells so
good okay so what else if people are
really looking for
a full family dinner
you know what what are they getting full
family dinner we have a variety of
pizzas we make all of our own pastas in
house we have a gigantic 36 ounce ribeye
tomahawk steak they come in order and
share the whole fish is great
stuff for the kids
um you know we also have a couple great
things that we do throughout the week
mondays is the viva vino for locals so
you get half price wine all day we love
the sound of that yeah and then
wednesdays we do our house party which
is our industry night so each week a
different one of our partners that we
work with uh from the alcohol companies
sponsor it we do half price on all the
pastas which include the lobster pasta
and the truffle which are the big
sellers and then also half price on the
featured cocktails that night how fun is
that okay quasi beach house is it best
to make a reservation
always the safest especially we do a lot
of large parties a lot of celebrations
so we can accommodate all sizes but you
know locals everybody else just walk in
whenever you're there if you don't have
one so all right there you have it
truffle pizza for new year's i love
thank you chef josh pleasure thank you